Now, the answer--that's a 60% and here is why.
At the threshold of Herd Immunity, the expression in the red parenthesis has to be 0.
If we vaccinate even more persons, the number of susceptible persons shrinks further,
and this expression becomes negative, and now we can solve for the number of susceptible persons.
And we get 1/5 days divided by this coefficient--the days answer
and we get the number of 40 million persons--that's 40% of the population of 100 million.
If the number of infectious persons is negligible at that point of time,
the remaining 60% have to be in the R compartment of the model.
They have to be immune.
If more than 60% of the population are in the R compartment, this expression is negative
and we can never have an epidemic outbreak.
So 60% is the threshold of Herd Immunity.